it's crazy it's uh once again if i was
to write this let's say 10 years ago as
a political thriller it would go in the
science fiction and this dystopian
thriller aisle at the bookstore no one
would have believed it if i had written
the exact same things that are going on
in this country today and
internationally and put that into a
novel it would have been unbelievable
the reviews on amazon would say i can't
believe any of this uh you know this
would never happen that sort of thing
one star uh but lo and behold look
what's going on
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
navy seal sniper a number one new york
times best-selling author and now author
of the brand new book in the blood
jack carr finally welcome to the reuben
report oh thank you so much for having
me on great uh great to see you i have
wanted to have you on for quite some
time uh first off i gotta say uh i had
to say number one
new york times best-selling author even
though the new york times left me off
their best seller list just weeks ago
but you got the number one spot it's
still credit to you so it sort of
stabbed me a little bit i'm kind of in
the blood right now but you deserve the
credit and i went ahead and did it
anyway well i sincerely appreciate that
and as we know you know it's hard the
number one and number two maybe number
three slots on that list like it's hard
for them to ignore but they have some
flexibility down there with the with
those other ones as a uh as an editorial
uh i think it was found i don't know 30
40 50 years ago whenever that was uh
brought up to the courts so uh so they
have a little flexibility there but
that's why the goal has to always be
number one so they can't ignore you
exactly exactly well you did get number
one it says it right here the i just
said to you before we started the cover
this book is just awesome the colors
they just it just freaking hits you got
a couple of them behind you so first off
i just got to start with i mean your
whole operation there i'm feeling very
stuffy right now you are obviously this
is you are in your your bunker somewhere
safe what's going on over there this is
true undisclosed location but i like to
be surrounded by things that that mean a
lot to me the uh the crossed winkler
tomahawks that are used in the book and
that amazon actually allowed us to use
in the series and feature prominently
with chris pratt that's coming out this
summer but probably like this one this
is uh hemingway's typewriter right here
a movable feast on this it went up for
auction with a bunch of other hemingway
stuff in uh january early february of
2020 so right before the cove at panic
really hits and uh and a fan got it for
me and didn't want to be recognized but
uh knew i had this just a fan of
hemingway and thought that i would enjoy
this and uh that i would appreciate it
and so they sent it to me with all the
documentation and the whole thing and
yeah it's crazy so uh that inspires me
as i as i write man you know you've done
something right in life when someone you
don't know buys you ernest hemingway's
typewriter it's crazy crazy solid pretty
solid so so for my audience that that
does not know you or or only knows about
you from your writing et cetera et
cetera give me a little bit of the
history the the navy seal all that stuff
because you have pretty extraordinary
history yourself
well i appreciate that and uh yeah i
feel very fortunate in that i always
knew i wanted to serve my country in
uniform very early age my grandfather
served in world war ii and uh didn't
make it home he was killed in the
pacific in may of 1945 but i grew up
with the maps that used to give aviators
back then which were silk so that if
they got wet you could still use them
and they didn't disintegrate like paper
uh pictures of him in his squadron his
metals his wings he was a marine aviator
so i was just drawn to the military from
a very early age and then uh at the ripe
old age of seven i found out about seals
and uh my mom was a librarian so we went
down to the local library to do some
research and uh there wasn't very much
written about seals or special
operations back then there were a few
articles here and there a couple
chapters in a book or two but my take
away that hey these guys are some of the
most elite special operators in the
world and the training is some of the
toughest ever devised by a modern
military uh so whether that was true or
not a seven-year-old jack was all and
the recruiter had to do nothing uh
essentially i made their job very easy
so i kept my my eyes on that for really
my entire life but i also started
reading the books that my parents were
reading in about fifth grade so that's
when tom clancy's hunt for red october
comes out and i'm reading david morrell
and nelson demille and a.j cornell and
j.c pollock and mark olden and all these
guys whose protagonists whose main
characters had backgrounds in vietnam
either as like marine snipers back then
or it was navy seals or army special
forces or cia paramilitary that was the
typical background of your
action hero in the thriller genre and
then on screen as well so it was so
magical for me to read these books and i
those guys were really my
my professors in the art of storytelling
although i didn't look at it like that
at the time they were i was just a fan
and i knew that after my time in the
military i would write books like this
the books that i was enjoying as a kid
growing up so i never stopped that
reading never stopped that studying of
warfare whether
terrorism insurgencies counterinsurgency
special operations uh that was all just
a part of my upbringing and it was part
of the foundation that allowed me to to
be the operator that i was the leader
that i was in the seal teams and then
all that comes together as i'm getting
out to write these thrillers so i did 20
years on the seal team started out
enlisted was a sniper then became an
officer finished up as a troop commander
and uh
interestingly enough that's where the
reader meets my protagonist in my first
novel he's a troop commander on his way
out and then disaster and conspiracy
strikes and off we go to the races crazy
how those things connect huh
it is and it wasn't the intent i thought
there are going to be two separate
chapters in life but when i sat down to
write that first one it became readily
apparent that it was going to be more
than just the technical details of a
sniper weapon system or something like
that it was really the emotions and the
feelings behind certain events that i
was involved in that i could bring to a
completely fictional narrative so if my
main character james reese is getting
ambushed in los angeles i can go back
and remember what it was like to be
ambushed in baghdad in 2006 at the
height of the war and i can take those
feelings and emotions and apply them to
this completely fictional narrative
which is why i think it stood out to
simon schuster who sees thousands of
books like these cross their desks every
year
yeah give me give me like the best and
worst
moment of of being a seal i i suspect i
can guess the worst but maybe maybe the
best
yeah the worst obviously is uh you know
when your friend doesn't make it home
and you go to those funerals and you
pound your trident into the coffin and
you see that widow or the kids um and so
that's obviously the worst part of it um
but uh the best part of it gosh you know
i never really thought of the best part
of it but i think it's the entire
experience in that you are you have a
purpose you have a mission uh your
passion is being the best operator that
you can possibly be uh you owe that to
the guys to your right and left to their
families uh to the team to the the
country as a whole to that entire entire
mission so i think it's that i guess it
would be the uh having that purpose that
is so clearly defined and when you're
downrange being solely focused on that
task in hand and not having to worry
about anything else not worrying about
the leaky faucet or the gutters or the
baby that's crying or whatever it is you
are solely focused on that task at hand
building patterns of life on your
targeted individuals and then going out
and grabbing them in the middle of the
night to bring them back ask them a
couple questions and then uh go go take
out the rest of that network so
having that that purpose that is so
clear i think is probably one of the
best parts
so one of the things that i'm always
amazed by is that those those of you
guys that have been in the military been
sealed been in the navy whatever it is
or people that have been in the cia the
fbi just a couple weeks ago i had brian
dean wright on the show i don't know if
you know who he is but he's a former
former cia guy
um people that get out and then do
things that are ancillarily related to
this whether it's talking on youtube for
a living
whether it's writing books that are
either fiction or non-fiction everything
else how do you blend
you know some stuff that they probably
don't want you to talk about there's a
way that you have to fictionalize some
of these things
you don't want to get in trouble you
don't want to become a character in one
of your books how do you take all of
those things and make it honest and
sensible and also you know not so you're
going to get yourself killed literally
right so a lot of people think on the
outside looking in that navy seals know
all sorts of secret stuff and uh you
know maybe there's a couple things here
and there but really what we're doing is
what every major city swat team is going
to do tonight they're going to go serve
a warrant they're going to go do a do
either a no knock or a knock warrant
somewhere they're going to bust in and
they're going to grab a fugitive uh so
we're doing that same thing except ours
happened to be in baghdad or kabul or
somewhere somewhere like that and we
have a few more maybe assets at our
disposal to build these these targets uh
build these target packages and then go
prosecute these targets but there's not
much secret about it i mean you're just
you're going up and kicking a door in
the middle of the night and grabbing
somebody out of their bed essentially
and uh but but you know i still wanted
to make sure that i was uh complying
with all the everything that i'd signed
in the military and i didn't want to
give anything anything away and at the i
was still closely related it's closely
connected to my military time for that
first novel so i submitted it to the uh
like i had got some lawyers and they
said yeah we recommend you submit this
so i did and they took out i think like
nine sentences so not not much it was
pretty good they make it back to me with
uh with 45 days they advertise uh 30 and
what you sign says they will get back to
you in 30. they got back to me in 45 i
thought that was pretty good for uh for
the government so i did the second one
as well that one one month went by then
two then three then four then seven and
we had to push the publication date uh
and they got back and they took out 54
sentences passages words
so at this point uh i can afford a
little bit uh afford some more attorney
fees so we go and we appeal and we tie
each and every one of those redactions
to a publicly available government
document so not to somebody's book or to
wikipedia but something anyone in the
world can download from our very own
government
they let me win on 37 so now you can go
to the paperback and you can look in
there and you compare it to the
hardcover and you can see what they were
concerned about but that i won on appeal
one of those things i made up a
completely fictitious cia black site in
morocco they took out morocco they took
out moorish architecture they took out
the atlas mountains they took out
everything that uh could pinpoint where
it what country this can i had no in my
military experience no touch points with
uh moroccan intelligence services or
military anything like that i just made
it up but by doing that appeal what are
they telling us well now they're telling
us that there's probably a cia
so if they've done nothing it would be
would have been more beneficial to them
than had they gone through this process
so i did that for the first three novels
the the third one they when we appealed
they got back and said hey uh we're not
gonna let you appeal and i took that as
uh you know quit bothering us kid with
his fictions we're not gonna let you
appeal that's probably the best thing
you can hear from the government in yeah
i'll take it so the next one was uh i
went deep down the rabbit hole in my
fourth one into uh bioweapons and
bioweapons research and so i'm glad i
didn't submit that one i was all
once again i had no touch points with
bioweapons in the military but i went
deep down the rabbit hole and then on
this one on in the blood deep down the
rabbit hole on quantum computing
artificial intelligence and uh mass data
surveillance and data storage of us
citizens and that was uh more terrifying
than the bioweapons research that i did
on the previous novel
that sort of tells you everything you
need to know
about that
um
so you're making the the movie and as
you mentioned uh chris pratt is going to
be in the movie and and chris pratt who
who's an awesome actor and what i think
is so interesting about him is the guy
has managed to stay in hollywood despite
his politics being outside of the norm
of uh of hollywood
how involved were you in in the casting
and just the creation of the movie
because obviously you
writing a book
doing it in your little operation over
there i don't know how i can't say
little but your very cool operation over
there is very different than when you
hand your baby over to hollywood and
hollywood may not be so in line with
perhaps some of the things in the book
perhaps the type of people that you want
involved etc etc
exactly i didn't know what to expect
going in just like i didn't know what to
expect from simon schuster going in i
thought you know they might want to
change everything and uh give me some at
least maybe hint that maybe i shouldn't
be uh do you really have to put this in
there about the second amendment or does
your character really have to think this
way they have never even hinted at me
changing anything i've had complete
creative control which is amazing but
when you option something especially
when it's before your first novel even
hits shelves you're not really getting
from a position of strength uh and so
they have all the rights can do whatever
they want and so when you're in that
position there's a lot of trust involved
and i was so lucky that i had chris
pratt antoine fuqua as the director an
incredible show runner and uh the three
of us just got together in the beginning
and what was important to all of us was
keeping that good dark gritty violent
primal nature of the of the book because
that's really what resonated with people
and broke it out from maybe others in
the in the genre but the way that chris
pratt even found out about it before it
hit shelves is interesting and that i
got a call from a seal buddy in november
of 2017 so a few months before the
book's gonna come out and first he asked
if i remembered him which i did and then
he asked if i remembered what i did for
him in the seal teams which i did not
and he said uh you're the only person
that sat me down in your office helped
me through the transitioning out of the
military introduced me to people in the
private sector nobody else did that
always wanted to say you and i said
how's it going and he said well it's
going great but i heard you wrote a book
and i said yeah it's coming out a few
months i can send you a galley copy it's
like a rough draft thing and uh and he
said yeah i'd like that but i'd like to
give it to a friend of mine and i said
who's that and he said chris pratt
and what was even more interesting about
that is that as i was writing i thought
of chris pratt playing the main
character and i thought of antoine fuqua
directing and another seal buddy got it
to antoine fuqua who wanted it and chris
and answered it at the same time so
finally antoine called chris and said
let's do this together and now we're all
executive producers on this thing but uh
it's uh
credit to amazon for the things that
they could uh well they were concerned
about a few things from the book uh but
really all that ended up being was
concern and uh once we we talked about
different scenes that we needed in there
uh and wanted to have in there that the
fans would want in there they came down
on the right side of it each and every
time as uncomfortable as it may have
been for them they uh they they sided
with us and it's it's all in there so i
couldn't be happier with how how that
worked out
what do you make of the state of sort of
the um
the mil well what do you what do you
call the genre actually you call the
like military thriller or like what
if you have to put it in something
that's a political thriller for the most
part but there's all sorts of thrillers
out there you know there's a lot legal
thrillers and medical thrillers and
dystopian thrillers and all that stuff
um but yeah it's political thriller so
political thrillers and i think of the
more in certain like there's certain
political ones that are very much in the
politics part and then ones that are a
little more in the military part i can
think of so many you mentioned tom
clancy i mean i can think of so many
incredible movies uh from the 80s or
really sort of early 90s that were just
like there were just every other week
there was just another awesome movie you
mentioned hunt for red october um
what do you make of the state of the
genre right now because you know
everything is so politicized these days
i find when i when i open up netflix or
hulu or amazon
for me personally as a politics guy i'm
often trying to avoid politics a little
bit that's that's just me but what do
you make of the general state of things
and i'm a guy i love explosions i love
thrillers i love all of these movies i'm
just curious what your take on that is
yeah it was something that i was
concerned about going in that other
people
that were involved in the project were
concerned about as well because as we
all know if you've scrolled through any
of the streaming platforms or gone to a
movie recently it seems like a lot of
the movies are made for people in la or
new york uh and forget about everyone in
between so we really wanted to make sure
we didn't forget about everybody in
between and uh it was interesting in
that a lot of people's view of hollywood
comes from seeing maybe a clip of the
academy awards or a golden globes and
sense of actor or director or producer
on stage saying something kind of crazy
and you're kind of like oh hollywood
people are all totally weird and oh my
goodness i can see where this is going
um but on set it was i had 350 people on
set making this uh series it's an
eight-part series uh for for amazon and
uh
i'm in this thing called video village
so the executive producers we have our
screens and we have our headphones on we
can watch what's going on and make notes
and and all the rest of it and the other
executive producer told me they hadn't
seen this before but uh so many people
on that set would come up track me down
there and like the hair and makeup
person would come in and say hey my
my son is going to boot camp tomorrow
he's a huge fan he follows you on
instagram uh would you sign a book and i
always had a big box of books there and
would sign away or someone would come up
and say hey my son's going on his first
deployment can you sign this for him and
absolutely and so we talk about guns we
talk about land cruisers we talk about
knives um we talk about hunting and just
normal people talk and what uh what was
it so extraordinary is that they're so
good at their job uh but also they just
want to put food on their on their
family's table and these are just normal
americans that are working hard and we
had american flags up all the teamsters
truck had their american flags flying
and it was uh it was a special set and
people made a point to tell me that
they've been on hundreds of sets and
they've never felt one uh that was uh as
open and welcoming and encouraging and
positive and just a cool and american as
this one and i thought that i was that
way that made me feel good anyway i can
tell you as somebody that just fled los
angeles after eight years there there
were awful lot of people that i knew
that were in the biz that were waking up
you know that were sort of lefties their
whole life or were into a lot of the
craziness and suddenly they were going
wait a minute i can't get a job because
i'm a 60 something year old white guy or
i don't fit this diversity thing or
something else or their the street that
they live on was burning down and they
suddenly got guns i was one of those
people in la that didn't have guns
before all this craziness and then
suddenly reality hits you in the face
and you you kind of change your view on
things
yeah i got so many texts uh when when
first one coveted hit and people were a
little worried about hey there's gonna
be food on the shelf or is somebody
gonna be there at the other end of when
i call 9-1-1 uh then of course when the
somewhere of civil unrest hit us a few
months later uh the same thing i was
getting texts and and phone calls and
emails from people in california in
particular uh asking about what gun
should i get and then them being
surprised that they just can't run down
and just get one we'll take they cash
and walk out with one the same day uh or
why they couldn't get ammunition sent to
their house in uh in los angeles these
things were a shock to a lot of people
uh who just from what you think in the
news is that oh yeah anybody can just
walk in you walk out with you know some
fully automatic boom boom and stacks of
ammo and all that stuff yet they've been
voting people into office there for so
long that uh that they don't have those
rights anymore uh they've outsourced
those to a to a government that uh is
surrounded whose leaders are surrounded
by taxpayer-funded security when they're
trying to take your rights away and we
see that of course all across the
country now but california uh chicago of
course a couple other play new york uh
stands out uh
stand out from the crowd in that regard
so i did get a lot of phone calls like
that and there were a lot of shocked
people that they couldn't just go in and
get any firearm that they wanted you are
preaching my language brother actually i
can't i can't say who it is out loud but
when all hell was breaking loose in l.a
i happened to say on the show one day
i'm thinking about getting guns for the
first time and i got a call from a major
hollywood sitcom star a woman who would
never want me to say her name on air uh
and she said hey if you need guns let me
know and she ended up connecting me with
people and that's how i was able to get
guns because yeah you're right you
couldn't get ammo either in la because
it was because so many people were
flipping on all of this stuff do you
feel a certain uh oh sorry good noise
you couldn't even order it there's that
you can't even order and get it
delivered and in los angeles it's uh
it's i think that's just a county thing
but but anyway yeah they make it
extremely difficult in the military it
would be like uh
motorcycles on base so they didn't want
you to ride a motorcycle on bay so first
they did okay you have to take this
course okay so you have to take like
three days to take take this course so
okay you gotta take this course you have
to do like an up you do it every year
and then you have to have gloves you
have to have shoes that cover your ankle
you have to have long sleeves helmet
reflector vests they started adding all
these administrative requirements and
finally it's like okay you win i'm
exhausted my whole this whole year is
going to be trying to figure out how to
ride my motorcycle onto base here you
fine you've got it so that's kind of
what uh you know what governments do to
try to make it if they oh we're not
making guns illegal well you're making
them administratively impossible to get
like you've done with concealed carry
permits in a lot of states that's
actually a perfect segue to what i
wanted to get to next relative to just
generally what's going on with the
military what do you make of the state
of the military at the moment and the
state of the way that it seems
politics has really infected the
military at least in the last
say five ten ten years that it didn't
seem it did before maybe we didn't know
about it before
yeah so uh obviously politics has been
creeping into all aspects of our culture
for a long time uh people like to point
to hollywood but hey look at there's
wall street more and more into sports i
mean almost every ass education of
course um literally every aspect of
society we thought the military was
immune from that and uh we found out
over the last couple years that it is
most certainly not um and really not
even talking about that woke us in the
military or anything like that we can
just go and look at 20 years of our
experience in iraq and afghanistan and
how none of our senior military leaders
have been held accountable for the
decisions that they made and we can go
back and look at each and every one of
these guys the stars on their shoulders
sitting in front of congress saying the
exact same things year after year you
can take the year off there and it's a
different person but the audio will be
exactly the same
meeting our milestones the the afghan
national army is getting closer to being
able to stand up on their own we just
need more resources more people more
funding uh more equipment whatever it is
and uh then the afghanistan papers was
published and i hope more people read
the afghanistan papers by craig whitlock
because what he does is takes these
interviews that the senior level leaders
thought were going to remain classified
juxtaposes it with what they were saying
in front of congress so to the america
to congress to their troops and
essentially you have
two separate stories 180 out from one
another
and so they are essentially lying to
their troops lying to congress lying to
the american people and these senior
level leaders continue to fail up and we
see what happens when we continue to do
that year after year and hold no senior
level leaders accountable we have a
withdrawal from afghanistan that looks
like what we saw last august which the
media of course doesn't even talk about
anymore but we all got to watch with our
own eyes and it's also why everyone in
this country with a little bit of common
sense uh could could comment on it
because you didn't need to have a touch
point with the military or study
strategy or tactics or military history
at all you could just look at that and
apply some common sense which is
something that carl von klauschwitz said
was most important aspect of any
military leader any combat leader is
having common sense and so anyone could
look at that and say why are we giving
up this tactically advantageous position
at bagram and putting america's sons and
daughters in a tactically
disadvantageous position when we've had
20 years to prepare for this eventuality
and this is the best the united states
military can do this is the best that
that we have this is what we're giving
or are giving our sons and daughters is
we're putting them in this position now
if you've done that at the tactical
level as an 0-3 so as a captain in the
army or lieutenant in the navy or
something like that or as a chief in the
navy or something a sergeant you would
be court-martialed sent home if you just
and our senior level leaders what do
they do
all those people are still in those
positions if they've retired they're
going they're on the board at raytheon
or general dynamics or something like
that so when we look at lobbyists and
politicians and think tanks and that
military-industrial complex that's a
that's a real thing that's an animal and
uh and when when it's not in hell to
check and no one's held accountable you
get things like the disastrous
withdrawal from afghanistan essentially
rushing to our death after 20 years of
being able to prepare and plan for that
eventuality it's uh it's inexcusable so
i don't know if you know this about me
but every august i take i go off the
grid for a month no phone no news
no communication with the outside world
i literally disappear for a month so the
the august uh this past august obviously
was the afghanistan withdrawal so i did
not know that until september 1st i come
back and i have a guest host it was adam
carolla this past year who kind of
caught me up to speed on everything so i
was seeing all those videos you know two
weeks later all in real time for the
first time in front of my audience and
what i said to adam watching them in
real time was
this from what i could tell just seeing
it all right in front of me right at
that moment all at once that this could
not have been worse that if you had
intentionally tried to bungle something
at the highest level that that's pretty
much what it would have looked like
do you think that's a fair estimation i
mean 20 years from now when we look back
on this thing what do you think the the
post-mortem is going to look like
well if it's honest it's going to be
exactly what you what you just said
right there you could not have have
bungled this worse had you actually been
trying um and once again it's that
accountability piece but you know what
we had we had 20 years of our own
experience to look back on to to take
lessons from to apply going forward as
wisdom we didn't even have to go back to
the soviets i mean we should have
earlier on gone back to 79 to 89 the
soviet experience in afghanistan we
didn't have to go back to the three
british incursions in the 1800s early
1900s certainly we didn't have to go
back to alexander the great genghis khan
although he could happen we could have
taken lessons from all of those things
and applied them to our present
situation as wisdom yet we did not we
think of things in terms of four-year
election cycles eight-year election
cycles for the real deep thinkers among
us um but we what we neglect to do is go
back in the pages of history take those
lessons and apply them going forward and
uh that's obviously the detriment of
our sons and daughters who are out there
on the front line and we saw in
afghanistan 13 lost their lives to say
nothing of those who lost arms and legs
and can't walk anymore um or dealing
with the post traumatic stress or
traumatic brain injury from uh from a
position that they were put in by our
senior level leaders is it crazy to you
to how quickly we just move off things
like that i mean as you said we it was
the longest war in american history we
were there for 20 years it was very
unclear to a lot of people sort of why
we were there and how it was connected
to 1911 and all of that stuff but that
basically
uh we had two or three weeks of sort of
news cycle and outrage and now it's it's
completely not talked about and you know
we've got this situation in ukraine
right now and it's like do our allies
trust us does anyone believe what we're
doing do we have the right people in
charge any of that
yeah no it's uh those are valid valid
questions and as it pertains to what's
going on in afghanistan vis-a-vis or in
uh in ukraine visiting russia once again
we had a lot of data in which to look at
and predict what was going to happen and
my second novel true believer i actually
use a false flag operation it came out
in 2019 but i use a false flag operation
to uh to instigate a russian invasion of
ukraine um and uh i got that just by
studying the situation at the time so i
was writing that in uh
2016 2017 um editing it in 2018 so it
could come out in 2019 but uh that
research should have shown anybody that
hey this is essentially inevitable
because the uh the russian population uh
is in a steep decline it has been since
the end of the cold war and they are
very a couple generations away from
there being no ethnic russians and
they're certainly very close to not
being able to field an army in the
numbers that they have had have been
able to in the past uh and at the time
it was about 2022. uh there's actually a
book uh called the accidental superpower
while peter peter zeon who looks at
geography and demographics as far as
world history and superpowers and how
that has has played in and uh yeah 2022
was about the last year that russia had
before they would not be able to field
an army capable of invading ukraine
because they need those ethnic russians
and ukraine has the largest population
of ethnic russians in the world outside
of russia
so these things were predictable um and
then of course we can go back to world
war one world war ii end of the cold war
promises made we rarely put ourselves in
our enemy's shoes and uh red game things
from that position um red cell things
from that position but uh we should do
that more often because we'd make wiser
decisions
what do you think the role of the
american military should be at this
point it seems like it really has
sort of changed or it seemed like it was
changing at least you know under trump
there basically there was a lot of peace
there was a lot of like oh if we mess
with this guy we don't know what he's
going to do you remember he dropped that
that mother of all bombs in iraq nobody
understood why and it was like well it
got pretty quiet there pretty quick uh
and now we we're in this ukraine
situation
what do you think the general role of
america
worldwide should be
well it it should be one of respect and
fear that goes along with that um
because that that military is really
what backs like the second amendment to
the first amendment um the military it
backs up everything that we say and that
we do uh so if we have this
strong military that is more concerned
with other people's borders rather than
than our own uh well essentially we're
seeing an invasion across our southern
border right now that's once again not
really talked about in in the mainstream
press uh it's been going for for quite
some time but we have all sorts of
issues like that and if uh and we have a
department of defense after world war ii
it used to be the department of war uh
the war department then it changed uh
1947 and really since then we haven't
done very well uh in in conflicts and
that's the exact same time that
accountability shifted and by shifted i
mean that we started not holding our
senior level leaders accountable uh when
we talk about george marshall he's most
known for the marshall plan after world
war ii but really what's more important
is what he did in their lead up to world
war ii and during world war ii which
were fire those leaders who didn't cut
it so he put all those guys in positions
whose names we know today as leading us
through that led us through world war ii
to victory um but had he not done that
and just let those people who are in
those places that weren't cutting it i
mean who knows how world war ii would
have turned out but he fired people that
didn't cut it after world war ii and we
shift over to the department of defense
things start to change korea vietnam and
obviously what we see today and we for
whatever reason we're hesitant to hold
these senior level leaders accountable
um but we can trace it all the way back
to the end of world war ii and uh in
1947 but um yeah today it's uh we're in
an interesting position and uh in that
yes we have a technological we have 20
years of experience and we have this
technology that has just been racing
forward when it comes to uh it comes to
our weapon systems and so we take those
tactical lessons learned take these new
weapons and uh and the technology as far
as tracking and targeting and all the
rest of it we should have the most
feared military on the planet yet we
have a border that's just
porous essentially and we're we see what
we saw in afghanistan so with all that
technology all those lessons we still
get that outcome in afghanistan so if
i'm the enemy and i'm looking at that
that gives me some wiggle room and that
gives me some lessons learned to apply
to my future battle plans that probably
go more than four to eight years in
advance i can think decades i can think
even centuries if i'm china and i can
apply these lessons to uh to that those
battle plans so it's not that hopeful i
sense
well my audience knows i always try to i
try to talk about the serious stuff and
then i try to there's got to be
something on the horizon somehow i mean
what what are some of the mechanisms we
could do to fix some of this stuff i
mean i don't sense that this
administration is going to go in and fix
the things you're talking about because
they seem to be aiding and abetting it
you talk about the southern border it's
like they're the ones that are freaking
opening this thing up 900 000 new people
roughly in the country in the last year
according to maorkus from department of
homeland security so like what are some
of the things that maybe could be done
to reverse some of the damage here
yeah first like the top three things
holding senior level leaders accountable
just like you hold junior level leaders
or soldiers uh sailors and
marines accountable uh so that's one
that sends a message because when you
don't what message does that send to
those people who want to put a star on
their shoulder or want to put another
one uh on their shoulder you're sending
a message regardless of which one of
those things that you do so holding
those guys accountable one of the top
priorities next one border sealing that
border that has to happen and then third
biggest one is becoming less reliant on
china particularly where it comes to
technology side of the house and
pharmaceutical side of the house so
things that we're i mean it's just
insane that we are reliant on
essentially our enemy for things that
are uh paramount to our national
security so those three things right
there um and they seem so simple once
again apply common sense to this problem
i mean that's what i did on the
battlefield you just look at the chaos
that's going on you look for gaps in the
enemies defenses you look to capitalize
on momentum you look to adapt because
the enemy's certainly adapting to you
that's what i do in the pages of my
novels and you can do that same thing
looking strategically at an issue so
those three things i think are uh
as simple as they sound somehow
escape the uh i don't know the thought
process and the strategies being put
forth by our senior level elected
officials not leaders i'd like to i like
to make sure that i differentiate
that
indeed they are elected i'll grant them
that leaders i'm not so sure at least
this current crop are you kind of amazed
though at the level of incompetence or
just general ridiculousness i mean
during the state of the union address
biden's talking about covet and he keeps
saying we're going to get everybody
you know kovid tests and then he's also
saying that we're going to you know
we're going to be making things in
america again he's suddenly repeating a
lot of the trump stuff but you know when
trump said it it was racist now it's not
racist okay and then the the tests show
up at everybody's house if you ask for
them and you're not going to believe
where they were made
it
china can you believe it like that level
of disconnect between i think this is
what you're getting to they say one
thing
then the stuff shows up at your door oh
covet test made in china we can't even
make the kovid test here this is one of
the two big things you were talking
about although it was mostly about
ukraine
yes no the uh they're made in china i
think when they first gave uh they
changed rangers in the army to uh tan
berets and i think when those those
first bats showed up they all said made
in china
and i think this is pretty september
11th you know going back in the memory
banks a little bit here but i seem to to
remember that uh that being an issue but
the levels of incompetence across the
board um and it's sad that i have to
include the military in that um but for
sure in the political space um i mean
it's it's staggering um but i think what
we're getting are people that uh it's
well it's interesting the people that
are called to serve our nation's
politicians also happen to be very savvy
investors it's it's incredible
it's it's so strange how they enter
politics and you know they get 60 grand
a year 100 grand a year 120 and then uh
you know leave with the bank account uh
significantly uh uh fuller than when
they entered uh because of some very
savvy investment uh moves so there there
is that um but uh the levels of
incompetence and the hypocrisy that is
just ignored by most of the media and
that means and this also ties into big
tech where you can now control not only
behaviors but thoughts so it's not just
buying something it is it's controlling
our thoughts now um and that part is uh
is then of course now we have the
ministry of truth and this
misinformation homeland security
department i mean oh my goodness
it's crazy it's uh once again if i was
to write this let's say 10 years ago as
a political thriller it would go in the
science fiction and this dystopian
thriller aisle at the bookstore no one
would have believed it if i had written
the exact same things that are going on
in this country today and
internationally and put that into a
novel it would have been unbelievable
the reviews on amazon would say i can't
believe any of this uh you know this
would never happen that sort of thing
one star uh but lo and behold look
what's going on so with all that in mind
although i sense that you're above
ground because i think i can see a
window or at least a reflection of a
window over there my guess is that
you're a little bit of a prepper to a
certain degree in that you're obviously
you're obviously at least self-reliant
to a fairly a fairly high degree let's
say
what do you recommend people kind of do
in terms of not being so reliant on on
all of these systems that don't really
seem to be working that well
right so i've always been into being
prepared in general since i was a little
kid it just was natural to me and as i
put more thought into it as i got older
it uh
i realized that hey for only a very slim
portion of human history have we been
able to outsource our protection by
calling 9-1-1 or having a standing
military
and then also being able to outsource
where our food comes from and just
having something that's wrapped in
cellophane that's labeled meat of some
sort that you grab off the shelf and
throw in a car without a second thought
of where it comes from what went into
getting that to the to the shelf we've
become very comfortable in this country
and for every reason my whole life i've
recognized that and uh just taking steps
to be as self-reliant as i as i can um
but we had a very slim window there
where people started we talked about the
guns in in la and uh where people
realized hey maybe society is a little
more fragile than i thought here and uh
for most of human history yes it has
been very fragile and for most of the
world today it is it's fragile look at
ukraine of course um so for a little bit
of time there some people questioned how
prepared they were how reliant they were
on the government um how reliant they
were on our our systems they get food
into our grocery stores um and maybe
they took some steps like you did to get
a firearm and get training with that
firearm um but a lot of people went
right back when things started to kind
of calm down a little bit went right
back to the the old ways and got very
comfortable again um but i think it's
just recognizing that hey society is
fragile and as a provider uh for me as a
children wife i'm responsible for them
and recognizing that we have this
responsibility and what does that mean
then well it means that i need to be
able to defend myself this gift of life
uh and the lives of my children my
spouse uh and then put field put food on
this table if we can't go to the grocery
store how are we gonna get get food on
that how am i gonna provide for them in
that respect um and you can go from the
the smallest most seemingly
insignificant thing until you need it
like a fire extinguisher uh does the
babysitter know how to use that do you
know how to use that let's go in the
backyard with the kids make a little
fire and have them put it out so that
the first time they're there they need
to do that they're not scrambling to
figure out and read the directions on
this thing so something from basic is
that to having a little bit of food a
little bit of water uh just so that
maybe you can make it a couple weeks uh
and then of course you can you can take
that as far as you want as you want to
go um and so we're fairly prepared here
if that uh
if that makes sense but it seems like a
very natural thing to do is just to be
prepared to protect that uh that gift of
life um and uh and once again if you if
you were dropped into this country or
into this planet let's say and uh and
were suddenly attacked by someone you
wouldn't need a document you would need
someone to tell you that you need to
protect this gift of life um you would
just do it because it's natural that's a
natural thing and a natural right um so
for some reason over the years we've
we've lost touch with how important
those things are and gotten soft and i
think that will eventually hate to be a
downer no no
you're giving me a lot well first off
you're very much speaking to the way
i've tried to live over the last couple
years because i really was i felt that i
was too reliant on the entire thing
which then i got guns i started doing
gardening we had backyard chickens in
l.a we're going to get them here and
we're going to get them here in florida
too i want to know you know i started
learning how to do just a little bit
more i love doing house projects now and
knowing how to do a little electrical
stuff and knowing how to do things
because you're right like we all became
reliant on things that man they can they
can go away pretty quickly so i got one
more for you that i think ties this all
together and so it won't be so
depressing but i don't think it has been
which is so for a guy that writes about
some pretty serious stuff and we've
talked about some pretty serious stuff
and that our systems don't seem to be
working as we wished
either domestically or internationally
and everything else um
are you hopeful and and what do you see
as the the course correction for all
this i mean beyond just okay we can
maybe fire some people elect better
people but what do you see as if you see
a real course correction to get us to
that better place
gosh yeah we're trying to stay positive
and the course correction is horrible as
it is um
i think it's gonna be just upon us by
some sort of a uh a seismic shift a
seismic event something like that that
that forces that hand because so you
think it's it's a rock bottom first
i i think so i mean it's uh it's
when you have two paths and one is very
easy and comfortable most of the country
seems like that's the way that they're
gonna go um and you have to really make
an effort to go that other way uh to to
be prepared to be self-reliant to
educate yourself to read books on
history and real and appreciate why we
have these rights and options and
opportunities that we do
and go back to the inception of this
country up until today and realize the
sacrifices that were made for us and now
we have people in this country that are
actively trying to restrict those rights
that people died to give us over the
course of our history so there's an
appreciation aspect there i took my
daughter to pearl harbor this last
december for the 80th anniversary
commemoration events we volunteered with
the best defense foundation and we took
64 veterans aged 96 to 104 back to pearl
harbor and uh these guys a lot of them
lied to get in because they were too
young to go defend their country and so
she had this touch point with this
generation that sacrificed so much for
us and then came home and got back to
work you know she'd read about them
she'd heard me as a parent talk about it
but it was different for her to sit down
across the daily table share a meal with
these guys hear their stories and they
loved talking to someone she's 16 and
talking to someone of her generation um
it was just it was incredible event for
her and i think it changed the direction
of her life actually so that ties back
into that appreciation of what we have
in this country and then what is our
responsibility to those people who
sacrifice so much for those next
generations what do we have to do now so
that future generations will have those
options and opportunities that we we
enjoyed and uh we're we're at a pivotal
moment in u.s history um and we talked
about the the first amendment i mean
we're on this platform right now we're
talking we're free to say whatever we
like here ish
but hey what about this ministry of
misinformation campaign uh
ministry of truth and and all that all
that sort of a thing and when we have
people who typically were the guardians
of that first amendment so let's say
lawyers publishing houses newspapers
magazines uh that used to be the front
line of defense oh my god they're
falling for censorship i mean that is a
that's a seismic shift right there that
should be alarming because the one thing
that used to bring us all together well
no matter what your thoughts are on the
second amendment or whatever else was
going on that first amendment bound us
all together as americans because we'd
stand up and fight and die for your
right to say something especially if we
disagree with you and now
that's changing and what social media is
weaponized and politicians want to
weaponize against one of what each other
so we can be more uh
divisive so that they can stay in power
and make those savvy investments that
they they are so uh so good at making
jack i think the uh final summation is
get a chicken coop is that what you were
basically trying to say the way you lit
up when i said chicken coop it's water
yeah yeah cause we have one
going in right out here um but uh yeah i
think it's just uh yeah appreciating
where we came from and taking some steps
to be a little more more self-reliant
and and that educating yourself and your
children along the way i think those are
the those sometimes that's all we can do
right on man the book is in the blood
i'm telling you guys this cover it's
just and it's this feels like a freaking
book i should have the book should be
here
we dropped the ball on that one the book
should have been there uh we're going to
link to it down below i've enjoyed
talking to you i hope you'll come back
great talking to you take care out there
thanks so much if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell